Hi, It's great to join you
at this year's Scientific
and Technical Awards Show.
Thank you to the Scientific
and Technical Awards committee
and its chair, Doug Roble, and
Vice Chair, Barbara Ford Grant.
With the help of
the volunteers who
have committed countless
hours of hard work, scrutiny,
and dedication that makes
these awards possible.
Unlike the subject of the
Lumiére Brothers' celebrated
short film, Arrival
of a Train at Ciotat,
the motion picture
innovation train never stops.
Its progress is, in fact,
vital to the art form.
From the earliest
awards ceremonies,
the Academy has
recognized and honored
filmmaking's pioneering
scientific and technical
advances, like synchronized
sound recording,
directional mics, image
compositing systems, and color
film, these achievements
and the many more
that followed represent
decades of focus, creativity,
engineering, and refinement.
Enter 2021, rising technologies
have found their way
into every sphere of life.
And they're disrupting
the creative process
at a breakneck pace.
Filmmaking shouldn't merely keep
up, it has the power to lead.
For example, the Academy
Software Foundation,
which since its
launch in 2018 has
been facilitating collaborations
among moving image innovators
through its vibrant
open source ecosystem.
Soon the Academy will be
convening its first ever
innovation summit.
It will bring together
industry leaders
and challenge them to envision
a bold, expansive, inclusive
entertainment future to chart
that future, to shape it.
But today, we paused
in the present,
took stock, got to know
some of our fellow riders
on this innovation
train, because today we
honored 55 individuals
and two companies
for their game changing work.
Oh, oops.